Let's do this one last time welcome back everyone
it's Charlie there are a bunch of big reveals and
announcements about the final season of The Flash
big crossovers we have The Flash movie pretty much
everybody coming back James Gunn's big reboot of
DC movies with a new group of characters coming
in real soon there's a lot happening in the larger
DC Universe so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos James Gunn did say that
he would reveal his DC Phase One of all the new
reboot movies that are coming before the end of
January so we're going to find out really quick
what those first couple of movies are going to be
he already confirmed the new version of Superman
it's like a younger version of Superman not played
by Henry Cavill but Henry Cavill did say that
he might wind up coming back based on what James
Gunn said like there's a chance for me coming
back in a future project I'll talk about that
later in the video because I still think that
they're building up to some sort of crisis on
infinite Earths in the movies it's just a little
bit different from what people thought that it
might have been before James Gunn was hired by
DC first thing though probably biggest news you
saw in your feeds recently is Stephen Amell
officially announced his return to the flash
as Oliver Queen he's come coming back in episode
nine there's only 13 episodes in the last season
you have to imagine Oliver Queen's Specter
coming back to slap Peacemaker for making
that dig a green arrow during Peacemaker season
one like green arrow no not like green arrow
a dude goes to Brony convention dressed in the
back half a Twilight Sparkle with a four inch
wide butthole drilled in the costume no I actually
heard that's true about Green Arrow but that's the
first thing he said that's real an Aquaman fish
well yeah obviously really great joke but it was
on top of all the Aquaman having sex with this
jokes in the old days episode 9 would have been
like the mid-season finale but the way they plot
these shows out the shorter runs and the way they
air the seasons is a little bit wonky so the
basic idea in the trailer you hear him say I
need your help it's not over please come help me
save the world that's probably Barry talking to
Oliver Queen's Specter character asking him to
come back and help and it's probably like right
before the final arc on the flashlight the final
batch of episodes where the really hits
the fan the last we saw him in crisis on infinite
Earths in the Arrow finale which happened right
after that he turned into the new version of
the Specter for the entire DC Multiverse and
if you remember they actually use the TV version
of crisis on infinite Earth to canonize everything
to like a larger DC Multiverse they're invoking
that in The Flash movie too like the whole idea
the did all the classic movies like Christopher
Reeve Superman the Christian Bale Batman all this
stuff happened in just alternate universes
that's why they had the footage from Batman
Michael Keaton's Earth Earth 89 they also had
footage from the Green Lantern movie in there
too and the way they explained his character is
that he's not just the arrowverse version of the
Specter for like that one Universe the Specter
is the embodiment of God's Wrath and in the DC
Universe there is a one true God like a capital G
God called The Presence he's like DC's version of
the one above all in the Marvel universe so it's
like one true God for the entire DC Multiverse and
one Specter the way they ended the Arrow finale
they kind of made it seem like the anti-monitor
took Felicity to the dimension where he existed
now and she just existed with like a sliver of his
Consciousness that remembered his life as Oliver
Queen like the rest of his god-tier Consciousness
was busy being the Specter across the rest of
the DC Multiverse so technically when he shows
up on the flash again in episode 9 he'll have
been on the clock for God this whole time being
the Specter since crisis on infinite Earths
they didn't say exactly what a story would be
other than it just sets up the final Arc of The
Flash like you see him in the trailer calling
out to him in the woods like Luke dude Earth's
in trouble please come help he'll probably come
back and they'll have some Easter eggs for his
debut like the flash debuted inside an episode
of Arrow season two when Barry first got his
powers Oliver Queen also guest starred during
the flash episode one and gave him a little bit
of a pep talk it'll probably be a version of that
kind of like the pep talk he gave him during
crisis on infinite Earths you can be better
because you can inspire people
in a way that I never could
watching over your city like a
guardian angel making a difference
saving people
in a Flash also probably giving a little bit of
cosmic help too like okay give you the pep talk
but also give him some cosmic power up too that
will help him with the villains because the whole
idea is that this is the final season of flash
they're bringing as many big characters back as
possible and introducing as many big ones from the
comics that they've been waiting to do this whole
time like they're doing Red Death finally they're
doing a version of cobalt blue so the idea is that
heading into the final Arc The Flash is getting
his ass handed to him and he needs Oliver Queen's
help the Red Death character in the comics is
a fusion of Batman who merged with Barry Allen
flash to gain his speed force Powers but in doing
so his Consciousness was trapped inside Batman's
new body if your big Dragon Ball Z or Dragon Ball
Super Fan it's just like Dragon Ball fusions like
the Gogeta version of The Flash they did a version
of this previously on a flashing a couple seasons
ago when he merged with Gorilla Grodd at the time
I assumed it was just meant to be a teaser for
them eventually doing Red Death like why would
you tease a fusion if you weren't going to do a
bigger Red Death twist in the future because
when they started doing the future arcs like
they started showing the future of Central City
Nora and what was happening many years down the
line they started to tease the Red Death character
in news headlines so like eventually we knew they
were going to do the character but because it was
happening so long ago I think at the time they
didn't fully know how they were going to pay off
that twist like okay we'll do red death at some
point and we'll just figure out who that's going
to be eventually it seems like they're still not
allowed to use actual Batman no surprise there so
I think they're saying that this red death is a
version of Batwoman they also teased a version
of cobalt blue in the season 8 finale who will
probably be played by eddiethon we'll see about
that there's been a fan Theory since the end of
season one like eight or nine years ago that Eddie
would be a version of cobalt blue eventually they
confirmed that Wally West is coming back they
confirmed that the arrowverse version of diggle
is coming back he did guest star on Superman and
Lois but that was sort of like another version
because that show is set on a different Earth
there was a whole big thing with diggle's Green
Lantern Arc I explained that in a previous video
because they weren't allowed to do genuine Green
Lantern stuff in a completely rebooted what was
going to happen with the Green Lantern TV show on
HBO like they completely changed their plans for
that they had to scrap all their plans for diggle
Green Lantern stuff and he basically gave up the
power he's like no no I don't want it and the Ring
went away definitely the least satisfying way to
pay off that storyline after all the Ezra Miller
stuff happened in the DC movies this year with The
Flash movie I was ready for James Gunn to call it
Grant Gustin to make him the new movie Flash
but he's finishing nine seasons of playing the
character I don't think he wants to sign up for
like another 10 years of doing that and whoever
James Gunn cast as the new Flash character I think
the idea is that he wants someone who can be the
character for the next 10 years there's been a lot
of rumors and speculations about who's going to be
recast who's coming back I think the idea right
now is that all these Snyder verse characters
like Ezra Miller most notably will be recast
after The Flash movie after Aquaman 2 comes out
and maybe in the future some of them will come
back via the Multiverse which I'll explain in a
second but if you're seeing that Ezra Miller might
stay on that's not really a thing like there are
a couple Executives that reportedly said that
we're amenable to Ezra Miller staying but it's
James Gunn who actually says who stays and who
go goes and James Gunn is the one that wants to
recast pretty much everybody so that means that
Ezra Miller is getting the boot after The Flash
movie and I'm not talking about the golden
boots which are actually in the flash poster
like they're doing the golden boots even though
they teased that a while ago in fact James Gunn
just posted about Wonder Woman debunking another
theory about when characters would start showing
up he says that he would announce like the next
eight to ten years worth of DC movies soon but
actually he's really only announcing the next
couple of years phase one introduced the new
versions of Superman Batman Wonder Woman Aquaman
Green Lantern yes Green Lantern there is reports
about them actually working on a Green Lantern
movie now the flash new cyborg build up to their
first Justice League rebirth Style movie where
they actually team up for the first time in the
next four years then they have their phase two
they fold in more characters than they have DC
Phase three and Go full blown Avengers end game
with the DC Multiverse which is kind of like
a crisis on infinite Earth Style movie there
are couple types of big crossover movies they
can do like there's a dark Multiverse movie you
could do after a crisis on infinite Earth there's
always the Blackest Night if you're talking about
bigger Green Lantern stories like the War of Light
originally they were using The Flash movie to set
up a version of crisis on infinite Earth in the
movies but that was before James Gunn was hired
and obviously James Gunn had very different plans
about who he wants the characters to be and what
the movies are going to be but he also might want
to work up to a Multiverse crossover light crisis
on infinite Earth in the next 10 years when Henry
Cavill said that even though he's not going to be
in the new Superman movie with a younger version
and he might come back later that's probably what
he was talking about like oh we're going to do
a big crisis on infinite Earth movie eventually
that's probably what I would come back and they
just say that the events of the Snyder verse era
of movies with those actors those Justice League
actors took place on another Earth and all the
stuff that James Gunn is doing is happening on
another Earth easiest way to hand wipe over that
I've talked about them using the flashpoint twist
in The Flash movie to explain some of that set
it up in a really small way like oh by the way
Flashpoint Flash is messing this up so everybody's
going to look a little bit different when you see
him again just really hoping that they pay off
that Grant Gustin Cameo scene with him having a
cameo in the Flash movie also John Wesley's ship
I'd be a little disappointed if they don't pay
that off the funny thing is I actually just did a
Flash movie trailer video because a new clip came
out that tease Michael Shannon Zod was going to be
one of the villains they have an evil version of
a Barry Allen Flash from Michael Keaton Batman's
Earth who's going to be one of the villains of the
film so that's why they're doing two versions
of Ezra Miller because the other one from his
Earth is going to be sort of like an evil version
of a kid flash like a younger Ezra Miller flash
right after I posted that video Warner Brothers
actually contacted me and they're like could you
please take out some of this footage like we don't
want this online like we're gonna pull your video
down all together if you don't remove this little
clip here but in that new trailer they just tease
when the flash is crossing the Multiverse the Ezra
Miller flash is crossing the Multiverse they have
scenes from all the classic DC movies like you
see Christian Bale's Batman you see a version
of John Wesley's ship as his version of the flash
from his show you see arrowverse characters Grant
Gustin is in there you see Linda Carter and yet
another Earth so it's just them doing the same
thing that they did on the TV shows was crisis on
infinite Earth just canonizing all of DC as part
of like a larger Multiverse like all this stuff
is Canon it just came from different Earths it's
all Canon through the Multiverse James Gunn should
be making a bunch of DC movie announcements in the
next couple of weeks make sure you enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss that of course
I'll do videos for whatever he winds up announcing
everyone click here for that brand new Flash movie
trailer and click here to learn about Ben Affleck
going back to Marvel to play another Marvel
character thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!